This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The Bowery in Lower Manhattan is one of New York's oldest neighborhoods, so it's been through a lot of iterations. In the 1650s, a handful of freed slaves were the neighborhoods first residents. This was back when New York was still a Dutch colony called New Amsterdam, and the lower east side of Manhattan was farmland. By the early 1800s, the neighborhood was a bustling thoroughfare with elegant theaters and taverns and shops. By the late 1800s, it had become a seedy place, full of saloons and dance halls and prostitution.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。曼哈顿下城的鲍厄里区是纽约最古老的街区之一，因此它经历过许多次变迁。17世纪50年代，少数获得自由的奴隶成为了该街区的第一批居民。那时纽约还是一个名为“新阿姆斯特丹”的荷兰殖民地，曼哈顿下东区还是一片农田。到了19世纪初，这里已成为熙熙攘攘的交通要道，遍布着优雅的剧院、酒馆和商店。而到了19世纪末，它已沦为一个藏污纳垢之地，到处是酒吧、舞厅和卖淫场所。
And by the 1940s, the Bowery had become New York's Skid Row. A place where down and out men could go and rent a cheap room for the night in one of the neighborhoods many flop houses. Now of course there's no room for a Skid Row on the lower east side of Manhattan, and the bowry, like the rest of the area, is full of expensive places to live in fancy grocery stores. But back in 1998, before the last of the flop houses closed its doors, Dave I say and Stacey Abramsson made one of my favorite radio documentaries of all time
到了20世纪40年代，鲍厄里区已成为纽约的“贫民窟”（Skid Row）。那是穷困潦倒的人们可以去的地方，花点小钱就能在街区众多的廉价旅馆里租个房间过夜。当然，现在曼哈顿下东区已经没有“贫民窟”的容身之地了，鲍厄里区也像该地区的其他地方一样，充满了昂贵的住宅和高档杂货店。但在1998年，在最后一家廉价旅馆关门之前，戴夫·伊赛和斯泰西·亚伯拉罕森制作了我个人最喜欢的广播纪录片之一。
about one of these places. These producers knew they were making a time capsule, but I don't think they knew just how fast and complete a transition New York was about to make. Even though most of New York City has moved on from these kinds of voices and stories, you'll never forget them. After you're here, Nathan Smith's riveting guided tour of the Sunshine Hotel. This is an eating and beaded hotel. Normally people come in and stay for a day or two and get out. But for some reason or another people come in and they like to stay for a year, for two years. In other words, they like to give you aggravation. If you like aggravation, come to the Sunshine Hotel. It's a lovely place.
关于这些地方之一。制作人们知道他们正在制作一个时间胶囊，但我认为他们并不知道纽约的转型会如此迅速且彻底。尽管纽约市的大部分地区已经告别了这些声音和故事，但你永远不会忘记它们。接下来，请收听内森·史密斯带来的阳光酒店导览。这是一家提供床位的酒店。通常人们进来住上一两天就走了。但出于某种原因，有些人进来后喜欢住上一年、两年。换句话说，他们喜欢给你找麻烦。如果你喜欢麻烦，就来阳光酒店吧。这地方很不错。
I didn't like the police in the bad, you know? The police? Yeah, I had police. I scratched all night, a couple of time hours here. Yeah, it wrote to us on the wall. I mean, it was a nice place, if you're short of funds, and you need to lay your head down for a couple of hours, we hope to make your stay pleasant.
我不喜欢那里的警察，你知道吗？警察？是的，我有警察。我整晚都在抓痒，在那儿待了几个小时。是的，它写在墙上。我的意思是，如果你资金短缺，需要找个地方躺上几个小时，这倒是个不错的地方，我们希望能让你的住宿愉快。
But don't ask me for towels or soap. We don't have it. We do not have those luxury. You want to see ID? Don't you want to come any time? No, I believe you. I mean, this is the kind of hotel where everybody gives an AK, and you're welcome to a room.
但别问我要毛巾或肥皂。我们没有。我们没有那种奢侈品。你想看身份证吗？你不想随时过来吗？不，我相信你。我的意思是，这是一家每个人都给个“OK”，并且欢迎你入住的酒店。
For a very nominal fee. Okay, here on my friend, you're all set. Thanks, everybody. Okay, you can squeeze yourself away. Just tell the other. This is the last of the last. Welcome to the Sunshine Hotel. Thanks a This is the last of the last. Welcome to the Sunshine Hotel. Thanks a lot. The last of the last.
只需支付象征性的费用。好了，我的朋友，一切都准备好了。谢谢大家。好的，你可以挤进去了。只要告诉别人。这是最后的最后了。欢迎来到阳光酒店。谢谢。这是最后的最后了。欢迎来到阳光酒店。非常感谢。最后的最后。
I'm headin' to be by the way. Headin' to me to Nathan, my friend. Excuse me. Okay. What's up, God? What's happening? All right, my man. My name is Nathan Smith. I am the manager of the Sunshine Hotel. Yeah, what can I do for you? I'd like to pay my man. My name is Nathan Smith. I am the manager of the Sunshine Hotel. Yeah, what can I do for you? I'd like to pay my rent. Good, you made the landlord a happy man. This hotel in 1998 probably looks the same as it did in 1920.
顺便说一下，我要去那边了。内森，我的朋友，去那边。打扰一下。好的。怎么了，伙计？发生什么事了？好的，伙计。我叫内森·史密斯。我是阳光酒店的经理。是的，我能为你做什么？我想付钱，伙计。我叫内森·史密斯。我是阳光酒店的经理。是的，我能为你做什么？我想付房租。很好，你让房东成了个快乐的人。这家酒店在1998年的样子可能和1920年时一模一样。
Like almost all of the flops. The lobby is on the second floor of a narrow flight of stairs. It's just a large room with wooden floors on a couple of chairs. I sit in a cage at the front running the joint. There's only one telephone for the entire hotel which you can keep safe, pretty busy. Zahnshine, give me a 10-4.
像几乎所有的廉价旅馆一样，大堂位于狭窄楼梯的二楼。那只是一个带有木地板和几把椅子的大房间。我坐在前台的笼子里管理着这个地方。整个酒店只有一部电话，你可以把它保管好，相当忙碌。Zahnshine，给我一个10-4。
Eddie, Eddie, Eddie, do me a favor. See if you can get an Earl Simpson. Tell Earl, it's his mother. Earl, Earl, Earl. Wake favor. See if you can get an Earl Simpson. Tell Earl it's his mother. Earl, Earl, Earl. Wake him up, wake him up. Throw him out the bed and dump him some up. Headed to the John, you gotta see me. Catch a tool to him.
埃迪，埃迪，埃迪，帮我个忙。看看能不能找到厄尔·辛普森。告诉厄尔，是他妈妈。厄尔，厄尔，厄尔。叫醒他，叫醒他。把他从床上扔下来，倒点什么给他。去厕所，你得见我。抓个工具给他。
35 cents of slice. I'll put it on your tab. You want a paper too? Okay, so this is small, thank you. Past the lobby, you'll find the living quarters for 125 residents of this hotel. The sunshine is one of the last places in the country where people live in cubicles. Maybe it's a little hard to imagine for those of you living in more fluent circumstances.
35美分一片。我记在你的账上。你也要报纸吗？好的，这很小，谢谢。穿过大堂，你会发现这家酒店125名住户的居住区。阳光酒店是全国最后几个人们住在隔间里的地方之一。对于那些生活在更富裕环境中的人来说，这可能有点难以想象。
Picture a long hallway with a series of doors on either side. These are the cubicle. Four by six, no windows. The cubicle's on the seven feet high, so this chicken wire along the top to keep the guys from climbing over into the next room. Really, it's like living on a bird cage. I'm Henry Fogelman, and I live in the 36A.
想象一条长长的走廊，两边是一排排的门。这些就是隔间。四乘六英尺，没有窗户。隔间有七英尺高，所以顶部有铁丝网，防止家伙们爬到隔壁房间。真的，就像住在鸟笼里一样。我是亨利·福格尔曼，我住在36A。
Basically, it's like the size of like a jail prison cell. It's got a light and bed mattress and a blanket with a screen wire on the top. And basically, that's about it. It's very tiny. It's so small. You have trouble making the bed. I've been in prison's jails. I've been upstate, downstate. Myself. For five times bigger than my room. So it's not the wall though.
基本上，它就像监狱牢房那么大。里面有一盏灯、一张床垫和一条毯子，顶部有铁丝网。基本上，就是这样。它非常小。太小了。你连铺床都费劲。我进过监狱。我待过州立监狱，也待过地方监狱。我自己住的地方比我的房间大五倍。所以这不是墙的问题。
But where else can you find a room in New York for $10 a night? If it wasn't for this hotel, a lot of these guys wouldn't have any place to go. All you have to do is look around like over there. You see that old guy with just no idea where he had to get to. This is Eddie. Eddie Bauer. Eddie Fink. There's about 100 people. There's a new day in San Chaud and the world's still here.
但在纽约，你还能去哪里找到每晚10美元的房间呢？如果不是因为这家酒店，这些家伙中的很多人将无处可去。你只需要环顾四周，比如那边。你看那个老家伙，根本不知道他该去哪儿。这是埃迪。埃迪·鲍尔。埃迪·芬克。大约有100人。在圣乔恩（Sunshine）又是新的一天，世界依然在这里。
We're still here. So that's good. Hey. Eddie sits all day in the corner of the hotel looking out the window and playing. I play you like Johnny Cash, you know what? That's my inspiration to Johnny Cash, right that's my inspiration Johnny Cash. The funny thing about Eddie is that he always plays the same songs over and over and over again. Maybe I might sit down and come up with a new tune in my mind, but by the time I pick up the guitar I don't forget the tune I had in my mind. Eddie used to work as a bandboard for Tito Puente, but he had a mental breakdown and ended up at this spot.
我们依然在这里。所以这很好。嘿。埃迪整天坐在酒店的角落里，望着窗外演奏。我像约翰尼·卡什那样为你演奏，你知道吗？那是我的灵感来源，约翰尼·卡什，对，那是我的灵感来源，约翰尼·卡什。关于埃迪有趣的一点是，他总是反复演奏同样的歌曲。也许我可能会坐下来，脑子里想出一个新曲调，但当我拿起吉他时，我就忘了脑子里的曲调。埃迪曾经是提托·普恩特的伴奏，但他精神崩溃了，最后来到了这个地方。
Hello, nice guy in the street. And he knew the barbie. And he told me, seven. You looking for a hotel? Come on with me, I'll show you a hotel. Just a place called Sunshine. It ain't bad. So we went together, right?
你好，街上的好人。他认识芭比。他告诉我，七号。你在找酒店吗？跟我来，我带你去一家酒店。这地方叫阳光。还不赖。所以我们一起去了，对吧？
That's how we started. That was 30 years ago. And he's still here. It's one of my plays, no. Somewhere...over the boundary. I need to be laying on you for another spot. You're laid up for me. My hands feel cold, they don't get enough feel.
我们就这样开始了。那是30年前的事了。他现在还在这里。这是我的剧目之一，不。在某个地方……在边界之上。我需要为你躺在另一个地方。你为我躺着。我的手感觉很冷，它们没有得到足够的知觉。
Sunshine is the last start. On the one hand, it's probably as close as you can come to living in hell. 125 dysfunctional guys crammed together in this old hotel. On the other hand, it's pretty interesting. There was some hotels on the balcony. I've had everything here from a priest to a murderer.
阳光酒店是最后的堡垒。一方面，这可能和你所能想象到的地狱生活最接近了。125个功能失调的家伙挤在这家老酒店里。另一方面，它相当有趣。阳台上有一些酒店。我这里什么人都有，从牧师到杀人犯。
You wouldn't believe the characters that stay here at the sunshine. For instance, you see that little elf and white guy walking through the lobby. That happens to be the only death new crack guy that's going to die. This is Donnie. He loves this place. This is our suit, Maven. He suits everybody in town. I think he's suing the Pope now for a mouth-easance or father O'Connell. You know what happened?
你不会相信住在阳光酒店的那些角色。例如，你看那个走过大堂的小精灵般的白人。那恰好是唯一一个要死的聋哑人。这是唐尼。他喜欢这个地方。这是我们的诉讼专家，Maven。他起诉城里的每一个人。我想他现在正在起诉教皇，因为渎职，或者奥康奈尔神父。你知道发生了什么吗？
This is Vinnie. This is Vinnie. What, Vinnie Giganti, cubicle 25 a. Vinnie has throat cancer and talks with a voice doctor. That's Vinnie, you know. This is the manager, he's the best guy ever. I've been here seven years as man's life
这是维尼。这是维尼。什么，维尼·吉甘蒂，25A隔间。维尼患有喉癌，用发声器说话。那是维尼，你知道的。这是经理，他是最好的人。我在这里当了七年经理。
might have adopted father. Then he looks a lot like the famous Marlborz Vincent to change your chances. Rumour hasn't that the guy is his uncle, all the while I don't know. I came in because I was a tinted arrow when I didn't want to bother my family anymore, so I'd been here since then, and I will be here until I die, bro.
可能收养了父亲。他看起来很像著名的马尔伯兹·文森特，改变你的机会。传闻说那家伙是他叔叔，我一直不知道。我进来是因为我当时很沮丧，不想再打扰我的家人了，所以从那时起我就一直在这里，我会一直待到死，兄弟。
That chirping sound you hear is Vinnie's two love birds. He spends all day in his cubicle taking care of. Yes, it's pretty, boy. He's 10 years old. This is a little bit. He's five. He's a devil. Yes, you all.
你听到的那种唧唧声是维尼的两只爱情鸟。他整天待在隔间里照顾它们。是的，它很漂亮，孩子。它10岁了。这是小一点的。它5岁。它是个小恶魔。是的，你们所有人。
They take good care of each other. If there wasn't for these birds, I don't think I'd have made it in this place. These birds depend my life. So many people on me are like, you need something. You know they'll be through everything or you're not going to make it. Hey, Pat. You get to do everything or you're not gonna make it. Tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk,sk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, tsk, t I grew up with 26 ounce of can of Chef Barri-D. That is for five people in the family. I'd be in a cold ready to can. That is a load of eats.
它们互相照顾得很好。如果不是因为这些鸟，我想我不会在这个地方活下来。这些鸟依赖我的生命。很多人对我说，你需要什么。你知道他们会经历一切，否则你活不下去。嘿，帕特。你得做所有事，否则你活不下去。我是在26盎司一罐的Chef Boyardee罐头中长大的。那是给家里五个人吃的。我会在寒冷中准备好罐头。那是很多食物。
That's a lot of grub there. Anthony's an orphan who came to the barri as a teenager, about 20 years ago. When I first met Anthony, he was a normal sized person. But something about this place caused him to eat and eat and eat. Anthony's gotten so large he doesn't fit in his clothes anymore he just walks around the hotel wrapped in a sheet and almost never leaves the building. Why should I go anywhere? If I'm one air I just open up to the window turning on my face a little higher than I got air. Excuse me. I've been trying to get Anthony to move to a hospital, but he won't go. I don't want to leave that yet.
那真是很多吃的。安东尼是个孤儿，大约20年前十几岁时来到鲍厄里区。我第一次见到安东尼时，他是个正常身材的人。但这个地方的某些东西导致他不停地吃、吃、吃。安东尼变得太胖了，衣服都穿不下了，他只是裹着床单在酒店里走来走去，几乎从不离开大楼。我为什么要到处走？如果我在这里，我只要打开窗户，让风吹在脸上，比我有空气的地方高一点。打扰一下。我一直试图让安东尼搬到医院，但他不肯去。我不想离开这里。
Too much like home. Too much like home. You've been in a place all such a long time. People get to be like family. You don't want to leave? Let this young fellow here. Just as my younger, my watch. Little white snack.
太像家了。太像家了。你在一个地方待了这么久。人们变得像家人一样。你不想离开？让这个年轻人在这里。就像我的弟弟，我的手表。小白零食。
That's Bruce, the hotel's runner, delivering two bags of Chinese food to Fat Anthony. That's another part of life in these old hotels. You see, up here in the sunshine, we're totally isolated from the rest of the world, so we create our own little society. Anything you want, you can get from another tent. We have a long shark, a drug dealer, a guy who does other tents, laundry for a couple of bucks, a room cleaner, and Bruce who runs errands for tips. All day, Bruce sits in a lobby waiting for runs and as soon as somebody calls him, then
那是布鲁斯，酒店的跑腿，给胖安东尼送两袋中餐。这是这些老酒店生活的另一部分。你看，在阳光酒店，我们与世隔绝，所以我们创造了自己的小社会。任何你想要的，你都可以从另一个租客那里得到。我们有高利贷者、毒贩、帮别人洗衣服赚几块钱的家伙、房间清洁工，还有靠小费跑腿的布鲁斯。整天，布鲁斯坐在大堂里等着跑腿，一旦有人叫他，然后
boom, he pops in the ax. Hey, T2 sugars, one role A, two packs of monarch non-filter, large bass tracin, one fact gin, same two packs anison. There you go. T2 sugars, role A. Bruce is a Vietnam fit, and for him running errands is kind of like going into battle. It takes constant concentration, constant alertness. The main thing is do the steps. Get the order.
砰，他就冲进去了。嘿，两份加糖的茶，一份A卷，两包无过滤嘴的Monarch，大份培根，一瓶杜松子酒，同样的，两包Anison。给你。两份加糖的茶，A卷。布鲁斯是越战老兵，对他来说，跑腿就像上战场一样。这需要持续的专注，持续的警觉。最主要的是做好步骤。拿到订单。
Remember who gave you the money and remember how much they gave you. Eleven should cover it, right? Okay. It's a work of constant steps and most of them are mental. T2 sugars, one role A, two pecs of monarch and walk in all the time. You've got people constantly distracting you. Distractions are bigger, standing on the other one side of the using. Oh, I need the T with two sugars. two pecs of monarch and walk in all the time you've got people constantly distracting you distractions are biggest and I'm not a better one-time using on either T with two sugars you get to the store T with two sugars you get the story you got to realize that you've got to be constantly be on guard constantly be on guard you're in the hustler's capital of planet every third person you meet is trying to hustle you out of your money store clerks included
记住是谁给你的钱，记住他们给了你多少。十一块应该够了，对吧？好的。这是一项持续的步骤工作，大部分是心理上的。两份加糖的茶，一份A卷，两包Monarch，一直走。你总是有被别人打扰的时候。干扰是最大的，站在另一边……哦，我需要两份加糖的茶。两包Monarch，一直走，你总是有被别人打扰的时候。干扰是最大的，我不是一个更好的人……两份加糖的茶，你到了商店，你到了商店，你必须意识到你必须时刻保持警惕，时刻保持警惕，你身处这个星球的骗子之都，你遇到的每三个人中就有一个想骗你的钱，包括店员。
how much of the money? 75. Okay, I give you a dollar. Now you give me. I give you a 50 same buy under me. You run every kind of person that's out for money in the world out there. And you got other people's money on you. You've got to defend it better than you will your own.
多少钱？75。好的，我给你一美元。现在你给我。我给你50，同样的买下我。你在外面会遇到各种各样为了钱的人。而且你身上还有别人的钱。你必须比保护自己的钱更好地保护它。
Because that's your livelihood. Your boy at once, you could ruin your career. You don't blow it. You can make sure everything's alright. My reputation is my business. I don ruin your career. You don't blow it. You can make sure everything's alright. My reputation is my business. I don't blow it. I don't blow it. 37 and $37,000, ain't you?
因为那是你的生计。一旦你搞砸了，你可能会毁掉你的职业生涯。你不能搞砸它。你必须确保一切都好。我的名声就是我的生意。我不会搞砸它。我不会搞砸它。37和37000，不是吗？
OK. OK. Keep that. All right. All right. All day long, I hear my tongue a phone ring. I'm a friend. You can do it.
好的。好的。留着那个。好的。好的。整天，我听到我的电话响。我是个朋友。你可以做到的。
Goodbye. Show time. Show time at the Apollo. I'll not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking.
再见。演出时间。阿波罗剧院的演出时间。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。
I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking.
我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。
I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm not drinking. I'm tell them. Leave $20 for cookie. Cookie with no tea? Right, I know cookie.
我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我不喝酒。我告诉他们。给Cookie留20美元。没有茶的Cookie？对，我认识Cookie。
Yeah, everybody's no tea. Yeah. In fact, my greatest wish is a day when I can have me a set of chops. You know? Yeah. And just get some. My name is Alton Morris and I'm 63 now. I came to the Sunshine Hotel in 1960. At that time, it was a bar all over the borough, you know, two or three bars in every block. And it was like Broadway, it never closed.
是的，每个人都知道茶。是的。事实上，我最大的愿望就是有一天能有一套假牙。你知道吗？是的。然后得到一些。我叫奥尔顿·莫里斯，现在63岁了。我1960年来到阳光酒店。那时，整个鲍厄里区到处都是酒吧，你知道，每个街区有两三家酒吧。它就像百老汇，从不关门。
And the whole borough was filled with nothing but alcoholics. And most of the people that I knew that was on the bar was dead. I mean, cause where I call. And so I'm lucky to be alive as I know that. Survived that those years on the bar, it's rough living. Yeah, really rough living. That's the season. Some historical facts about this joint. The sunshine was open in 1922 by a guy named Plank Masara.
整个鲍厄里区除了酒鬼什么都没有。我认识的大多数在酒吧里的人都死了。我的意思是，因为我所说的。所以我很幸运还活着，我知道这一点。在酒吧里度过了那些年，生活很艰难。是的，真的很艰难。这就是季节。关于这个地方的一些历史事实。阳光酒店是1922年由一个叫普兰克·马萨拉的人开的。
Cubicles were a diamond knight. His son called took over in 1945 and ran the place until a couple of years ago when he sold it to the New of now that looking for sell They should make this building landmark status Yeah sure, sure, sure, but at this place we be in the street a lot of guys here This is the only thing we can afford with this place The last men do not dwell this place is the last of the more I don't need all the sunshine You know, I got a I got a name, but I got a bunch.
隔间是一晚一角钱。他的儿子在1945年接手，经营到几年前，当时他把它卖给了……现在他们想卖掉。他们应该把这座建筑列为地标。是的，当然，当然，当然，但在这个地方，我们很多人会在街上。这是我们唯一负担得起的地方。这个地方是最后的……我不需要所有的阳光。你知道，我有一个名字，但我有一群。
You know what I mean? You know what I mean? Like all of the plots, the sunshine is a men's only establishment. Some of the hotels left on the bar are still whites only, but I let everyone in here. All races, all ages, all kinds of stories. We all have one thing in common. We're on our own. We all had homes, but for some reason,
你知道我的意思吗？你知道我的意思吗？像所有的廉价旅馆一样，阳光酒店只接待男性。鲍厄里区剩下的一些酒店仍然只接待白人，但我让每个人都进来。所有种族，所有年龄，各种各样的故事。我们都有一个共同点。我们都是孤身一人。我们都有过家，但出于某种原因，
we left or got thrown out. Take me, for example, I used to work in a bank until one day many years ago, I was injured on a job. They fired me and sometime later my wife left. So I came down to the Bowery and I'd been here ever since. What's the going? Take Terry in the back. Get time off and take me back. Some of my guys in here are drug addicts or alcoholics. Some are just off
我们离开了或者被赶了出来。以我为例，我曾经在银行工作，直到多年前的一天，我在工作中受伤了。他们解雇了我，不久之后我妻子也离开了。所以我来到了鲍厄里区，从那以后就一直待在这里。怎么了？带特里去后面。休息一下，带我回去。我这里的一些家伙是瘾君子或酒鬼。有些只是刚从
Rikers Island. Others just going to be. I'm gonna be on me a summer resort. I'm gonna have an audition put on for you. I'm gonna have four basketball courts. I'm gonna have around over 440 tracks. Track, track, they track. Oh, so you think I'm gonna go over and fish? You know what I mean? Once you just do one thing, you gotta have your reaction, mate.
赖克斯岛监狱出来。其他人只是……我要去度假胜地。我要为你安排一场试镜。我要有四个篮球场。我要有大约440条跑道。跑道，跑道，他们跑道。哦，所以你以为我要去钓鱼？你知道我的意思吗？一旦你只做一件事，你就必须有你的反应，伙计。
I'm having a summer re-door and this is what is going to be composed of. Like, yeah. Some of my guys here at the Sunshine of Working and trying to save a buck, some are hiding out from the law, some are dumped here by psychiatric hospital. Emotionally distraught people, find a home in the Sunshine Hotel, and I found home inside me. White is girl-colored, black is boy-colored, blue is emotion.
我要去度假胜地，这就是它的组成部分。就像，是的。我在阳光酒店的一些家伙在工作，试图存点钱，有些人在躲避法律，有些是被精神病院扔到这里的。情绪困扰的人在阳光酒店找到了家，我也在内心找到了家。白色是女孩色，黑色是男孩色，蓝色是情绪。
My name is Jeffrey Mangones. I live in the Sunshine Hotel. I'm from a family of multi-bullying areas. My mother is multi-bullying there, it's with my sister. And then there are those of us who end up here because we're dreamers and just don't seem to fit in anywhere else. Like my relief clerk, Vic, Vic spends his days in a corner of the hotel hunched over his daily racing form depressed.
我叫杰弗里·曼戈内斯。我住在阳光酒店。我来自一个多重欺凌的家庭。我母亲是多重欺凌者，我姐姐也是。然后还有我们这些人，因为我们是梦想家，似乎在其他任何地方都无法融入，所以最终来到了这里。就像我的替补职员维克，维克整天坐在酒店的角落里，弯腰驼背地看着他每天的赛马表，很沮丧。
But he wasn't always like that. In my case, I started off like probably so many people. Maybe everyone for all I know, with sweet dreams, you know. They grew up in Ohio with an alcoholic mother and abusive father. He always felt like a miss-fit, so he buried himself in philosophy and poetry books. And then set off for the Bowery in 1960 to live cheaply while undertaking his metaphysical journey. I had some crazy soaring ambitions of figuring out everything.
但他并不总是那样。就我而言，我开始时可能和很多人一样。据我所知，也许每个人都是，怀揣着甜蜜的梦想，你知道。他在俄亥俄州长大，有一个酗酒的母亲和一个虐待他的父亲。他总是觉得自己是个异类，所以他沉浸在哲学和诗歌书籍中。然后在1960年出发前往鲍厄里区，在进行形而上学之旅的同时过着廉价的生活。我有一些疯狂的雄心壮志，想弄清楚一切。
Figuring out everything. I was well the old impossible quest for truth. It's like singing from that song, what's it all about, Alfie? Who hasn't wondered what it's all about? Some fierce ambitions along those lines. I don't know, seemed like I was making some progress. It was intoxicating. And after a while seemed like it was some crazy pipe dream, as they say. I figure there, there, there, there, there, there, there, there, been a lot more substantial heavy weights than me by far through history, you know, and they didn't seem to come up with the answers.
弄清楚一切。我是在进行那场古老而不可能的真理探索。就像那首歌里唱的，阿尔菲，这一切到底是为了什么？谁没想过这一切是为了什么？在这些方面有一些强烈的野心。我不知道，似乎我取得了一些进展。这令人陶醉。过了一会儿，这似乎是一个疯狂的白日梦，正如他们所说。我想，历史上比我重得多、重要得多的人多得多了，你知道，他们似乎并没有得出答案。
The big answers, you know. So where did I get off thinking I had, you know, a chance for that? It seems like one of those stories better left untold. To me, it seems that way. I could get a name left here to the Sunshine Hotel, 241 Bar, he's one of my tenants. He's very ill. I'm Mr. Marshall, I think he's been five to eighty years old, he's seen Ile. Dumped here by his son about two months ago, he doesn't eat anything but Oreo cookies. Can't walk to the bathroom so he goes on the floor. Here he is now. He's down to 80 pounds now in John's. Marshall wouldn't last another week here in this condition.
大答案，你知道。所以我怎么会认为我有机会呢？这似乎是那些最好不为人知的故事之一。对我来说，似乎是这样。我可以在这里留下一个名字，阳光酒店，241号酒吧，他是我的租客之一。他病得很重。我是马歇尔先生，我想他已经五到八十岁了，他看起来很虚弱。两个月前被他儿子扔到这里，他除了奥利奥饼干什么都不吃。走不到厕所，所以就在地板上解决。他现在就在这儿。他在约翰的照顾下现在只有80磅了。马歇尔在这种情况下在这里活不过一个星期。
I called his son last night, but he doesn't care. Yeah, look at him. Don't you come on outside? Yeah, man. Don't. Don't. I mean, it happens, you know, place like this, you know, they, you know, we're very popular with people being dumped, you know.
我昨晚给他儿子打了电话，但他不在乎。是的，看看他。你不想出来吗？是的，伙计。别。别。我的意思是，这会发生，你知道，像这样的地方，你知道，他们，你知道，我们这里很受欢迎，因为人们被扔在这里，你知道。
Keep your hands on your left. Don't reach out to grab anything, right? Just lean back, relax, okay? The ambulance crew wheels Mr. Marshall out and Edwin out ported puts on a gas mask to clean up. He said he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, he's not a toilet, put it in the bag, yeah. The cubicle has covered with feces, flies everywhere, it smells like nothing you ever smelled before. You see a lot of urine all over the floor. A lot of those milk cartons full of urine. It's the worst part, cleaning up rooms like this. Yeah. What was gone was areas, Robinson was gone, Dave Rodriguez was gone. Late afternoon at the sunshine, my ship is almost over and I'm sorting through the mail. Rodney is deceased. This is the guy that got shot by the maintenance man here in the lobby.
把手放在左边。不要伸手去抓任何东西，好吗？只要向后靠，放松，好吗？救护车人员把马歇尔先生推了出去，埃德温·安波特戴上防毒面具进行清理。他说他不是厕所，他不是厕所……把它放进袋子里，是的。隔间里到处都是粪便，到处都是苍蝇，闻起来像你以前闻过的任何东西。你看到地板上到处都是尿液。很多装满尿液的牛奶盒。这是最糟糕的部分，清理这样的房间。是的。罗宾逊走了，戴夫·罗德里格斯走了。阳光酒店的傍晚，我的轮班快结束了，我正在整理邮件。罗德尼去世了。这就是那个在大堂里被维修工枪杀的家伙。
Over five bucks. Marcus is gone. Scott is like a death house. Okay, seven months I've been here, five guys have died. Okay, and these guys will never leave the building. I meet months and months at a time. One guy I knew that would leave this building for one year. He says, don't, says, I'm gonna die in this place, you know? And, you know, so it scares me.
为了五块钱。马库斯走了。斯科特就像个死亡之家。好的，我在这里七个月了，五个人死了。好的，这些人永远不会离开这栋大楼。我见过几个月几个月的时间。我认识的一个人一年都不会离开这栋大楼。他说，别，说，我要死在这个地方，你知道？而且，你知道，这让我害怕。
It scares me. I can't go to a lower than this. I can't. The only thing I can do now is start. Like a little chicken to start crawling out of the egg. I wake up in the morning and sit in the bed, smoke a cigarette, and say to myself, Donald, what the hell are you doing here? What the hell are you doing here? What the hell are you doing?
这让我害怕。我不能再低了。我不能。我现在唯一能做的就是开始。像一只小鸡开始爬出蛋壳。我早上醒来，坐在床上，抽根烟，对自己说，唐纳德，你到底在这里做什么？你到底在这里做什么？你到底在做什么？
Most of the people just lay on their bed all day and they're cubicle watching TV or listening to the radio or staring into space or sleeping and just keep vegetating and these little cells with fluorescent light overhead coming through the chicken wire and that's their life. That's a guy we'll call Max R. He didn't want his full name used. Cubicle 1L.
大多数人整天躺在床上，在隔间里看电视、听收音机、盯着虚空或睡觉，只是在这些带有头顶荧光灯、透过铁丝网照射进来的小牢房里不断地像植物一样生活，这就是他们的生活。那是我们称之为Max R的家伙。他不想用他的全名。1L隔间。
Max is a 30 year old Russian immigrant, a skinny kid with a ponytail and glasses. Unlike the other guys you've met Max is one of my short term tenants. He left his wife and kids in New Jersey and came me on a heroin binge two months ago. This is my chance to get away where I just don't have to do anything for anyone and just indulge to the maximum without being worried about what anyone's going to say or how I'm going to affect others.
马克斯是一个30岁的俄罗斯移民，一个留着马尾辫、戴着眼镜的瘦小子。和你见过的其他人不同，马克斯是我短期租客之一。他把妻子和孩子留在新泽西州，两个月前因为海洛因狂欢来到这里。这是我离开的机会，我不需要为任何人做任何事，只是尽情放纵，而不必担心别人会怎么说，或者我会如何影响他人。
No one knows that I'm here. It's just a complete getaway. Max is an architect and even though he's only been here for a short while, he managed to make his cubicle homey, lit with candles, their piles of books on the floor, and posters on his wall. There is a painting of a dearest St. Jerome who was a hermit. He went to the desert and lived by himself for a very long time to try to seek knowledge and achieve illumination. In a sense, that's what I'm doing too, I guess. It's some grotesque. And I enjoy it. It's like that movie that cooked the thief, the wife and her lover. The experience is so disgusting, so grotesque and they're so gross.
没人知道我在这里。这只是一个彻底的逃离。马克斯是一名建筑师，尽管他在这里待的时间不长，但他设法让他的隔间变得温馨，点着蜡烛，地板上有成堆的书，墙上有海报。有一幅圣杰罗姆的画，他是一位隐士。他去沙漠独自生活了很长一段时间，试图寻求知识并获得启迪。从某种意义上说，我想我也在做同样的事情。这有点怪诞。我很享受。就像那部电影《厨师、大盗、他的太太和她的情人》。这种体验太恶心、太怪诞了，他们太粗俗了。
But they make an arc out of it. I'm kind of making an arc out of experiencing this. A couple of days later, Max is arrested at the Sun Channel. When they crashed him up against the wall several times, and Han Cupden took him out of here. And that means his room is revealed for anybody who wants to rent. He's just a clean-out now. Nothing personal, he's a clean-out. You know, now I'm going to clean him out and sell his room.
但他们从中创造了一种艺术。我正在把这种体验变成一种艺术。几天后，马克斯在阳光酒店被捕。当他们几次把他撞在墙上，戴上手铐把他带走时。这意味着他的房间对任何想租的人开放。他现在只是个清理对象。没什么个人恩怨，他只是个清理对象。你知道，现在我要清理他，卖掉他的房间。
Maybe tomorrow. I'll probably sell it tomorrow more than like. All right, signing in my friend, signing in print. One tenant leaves, another checks in, but the hotel never really changes. The sunshine will always be a dark place. Wake up every morning with chicken wide, just above you walls,
也许明天。我可能会在明天卖掉它，很有可能。好的，签到，我的朋友，签到。一个租客走了，另一个入住，但酒店从来没有真正改变过。阳光酒店永远是一个黑暗的地方。每天早上醒来，铁丝网就在你上方，墙壁
heavy you in on all sides alone. It's a stunningly sad place to live. Sometimes at the sunshine I close my eyes and drift off. I forget where I am just for a second or two. Suddenly I'm not in a flop hotel but sitting in some family kitchen drinking a cup of coffee. Then I wake up and I'm back in a flop hotel but sitting in some family kitchen drinking a cup of coffee. Then I wake up and I'm back at the hotel. Just like everyone else here hoping for a break, waiting for that day when I can finally check out of the Sunshine Hotel for good. I hope you enjoyed your stay here while you were here.
把你围在四面八方，孤身一人。这是一个令人震惊的悲伤的居住地。有时在阳光酒店，我闭上眼睛，飘走。我忘记了我在哪里，哪怕只有一两秒钟。突然，我不在廉价旅馆里，而是坐在某个家庭厨房里喝着咖啡。然后我醒来，我又回到了酒店。就像这里的每个人一样，希望有一个转机，等待着那一天，我终于可以永远离开阳光酒店。我希望你在待在这里的时候过得愉快。
You were very good. I always tell my tenants the same thing when they leave. You're welcome to come back anytime buddy. Very good. Hey good luck buddy. Good luck. Good luck. Yeah.
你非常好。我总是告诉我的租客同样的话，当他们离开时。你随时欢迎回来，伙计。非常好。嘿，祝你好运，伙计。祝你好运。祝你好运。是的。
Good luck. Wherever they're going the next place I hope it's not the same as this. I hope it's a little better. But I always tell them that. Good luck. Good luck. That's all I say. Okay, walk me. Tony, you're going to help them. Yeah. them, good luck. Good luck, that's all I say. Okay, walking. Tony, you gonna help them? Yeah.
祝你好运。无论他们去哪里，下一个地方，我希望它不像这里。我希望它好一点。但我总是那样告诉他们。祝你好运。祝你好运。这就是我说的。好的，带我走。托尼，你要帮他们。是的。他们，祝你好运。祝你好运，这就是我说的。好的，走吧。托尼，你要帮他们？是的。
Good, good. I'm Nathan Smith at the Sunshine Hotel. Take care of my plan. Yeah, we should. God bless, buddy. Yeah. Okay. Go.
好，好。我是阳光酒店的内森·史密斯。照顾好我的计划。是的，我们应该。上帝保佑，伙计。是的。好的。走。
Go. Go. Go. Go. Good. Good. Good. Good. Good. Good. The Sunshine Hotel was produced by Dave Isay in Stacey Abramson in 1998. The narrator of this piece and manager of the Sunshine Hotel Nathan Smith died from cancer in 2002.
走。走。走。走。好。好。好。好。好。好。《阳光酒店》由戴夫·伊赛和斯泰西·亚伯拉罕森于1998年制作。这部作品的叙述者和阳光酒店的经理内森·史密斯于2002年死于癌症。
This documentary was a production of Sound Portraits which went on to spawn story quar which is dedicated to collecting, sharing, and preserving people's stories. They probably made you cry during morning edition on Fridays, but I'm here to tell you they also have a podcast that's much longer than what's on the air and it's hosted by StoryCore producers who offer more backstory and podcast exclusives and some older documentaries like this one. It's just great. So if you like these kinds of moving and affecting stories of everyday people,
这部纪录片是Sound Portraits的作品，后来催生了StoryCorps，致力于收集、分享和保存人们的故事。他们可能在周五早上的《晨间版》节目中让你流泪，但我在这里告诉你，他们还有一个播客，比广播里的内容长得多，由StoryCorps的制作人主持，他们提供更多的背景故事和播客独家内容，以及像这样的一些老纪录片。这真的很棒。所以，如果你喜欢这些关于普通人的感人至深的故事，
subscribe to the StoryCore podcast wherever you find podcasts. More info about StoryCore can be found at storycore.org. 99% Invisible is Sam Greenspan, Katie Mingle, Avery, Troubleman, and me Roman Mars. We are a production of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSign, an architecture and interior sperm in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, we're all on Twitter, Tumblr, Instagram and Spotify, but you can listen to every single episode of 99% Invisible at 99pi.org. Radio Tapio.
请在任何你找到播客的地方订阅StoryCorps播客。关于StoryCorps的更多信息可以在storycore.org找到。《99%隐形》由萨姆·格林斯潘、凯蒂·明格尔、艾弗里·特鲁布曼和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的作品，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的ArcSign建筑和室内设计公司办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目，我们都在Twitter、Tumblr、Instagram和Spotify上，但你可以在99pi.org收听《99%隐形》的每一集。Radio Tapio。
From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX。你。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。